hey everyone will welcome to the great
debate in honor of the premiere of
season 12 of RuPaul's Drag Race we're
gonna debate which contestant we think
should have won their season basically
who was the ultimate robbed Queen now
joining me today is one of Toronto's
most fabulous Queens known for hosting
the Gladstone Hotel super popular drag
brunch miss Mosu thank you so much for
being there for having me no just to
show you off a little bit we actually
have pictures of you with some of your
celebrity friends oh no big deal can we
drop some names here
I see Sarah Paulson Cate Blanchett
Elizabeth fangs lovely Todd Annie Murphy
they've all come to the drag brunch not
all of them
okay very impressive I need to go I need
an invite okay we need to do what we
need to make this happen
we also have the face of et Canada pride
with Stephen Kay here excited that
you're here is lo we see each other all
the time at work but we don't actually
get to do this together okay so how
excited are you guys for the new season
of RuPaul's Drag Race
I mean every season that comes there's
so much excitement around it it's an
easy breezy type of show where the
community gets together and we just have
a good time watching it but if you give
the new contestant I obsessed with these
Queens I think these might be some of
the best Queens we've seen really on
season 12 I mean these Queens are Queens
that probably started watching RuPaul's
Drag Race at such a young age that now
they've just developed into these
superstars already right it's gonna be a
good season there's lots of new york
Queens so I think there's gonna be a bit
of New York drama I think five ranks
from New York alone and guest judges are
impressive as well this season right oh
my gosh we have Jeff Goldblum Nicki
Minaj's on the premiere episode Robin I
mean it's gonna be so good Leslie Jones
there's so many good guest judges okay
it's gonna be good for the purpose of
our debate today we're each gonna get 45
seconds to reveal our choice now we do
have a special edition buzzer that will
go up if we go over our time let's hear
Shaye
so beautiful thank you Frank for coming
up with that that is awesome but we also
want to hear from you at home so tell us
who you think deserve to win their
season on RuPaul's Drag Race so Steven
we're actually gonna start with you were
gonna get that countdown clock up on the
board it's all up to you I'm red am up
first
all right so Brooklyn Heights is the
first Canadian to ever appear on
RuPaul's Drag Race and she was robbed of
the crown in season 11 and here's why
Brooklyn not only blew everyone away
with her incredible runway looks lip
syncs dance skills and poise but she was
an ice queen who managed to keep herself
out of the drama instead of inserting
herself in it and I love that I've seen
Brooklyn interacting with her fans and
she remains humble with all of her
success that said there has been drama
with season 11
evie oddly who was the winner not
treating her fans so greatly something
she has since apologized for sort of so
in the end who represents RuPaul's Drag
Race the best it would be Brooklyn
Heights and with that she's gonna be a
judge on Canada's drag race this year
and I know people are like oh it's just
because you know Brooklyn that's not
true watch let's watch a clip a tough
snatch David it was terrible and I know
I'm getting read to Phil for it so I'm
pulling out all the stops I need to
light that runway on fire
[Applause]
Rupali dad everyone whose dad yes did it
kiss blonds really do have more fun oh
yes she went from Crooklyn Joe Brooklyn
oh good we already have a comment Alyssa
I sang justice for Brooklyn justice more
Brooklyn I listen I think I think we may
see Brooklyn eventually on an all-star
season yes I think she deserves a crown
that said her career right now is just
out of this world
right so she needs to just build what
she is doing with Canada's drag race
with all these great amazing things
she's doing so she's doing it right but
she was robbed
okay we'll miss Mona see that it is up
to you now we're gonna get that
countdown clock back up on the screen
45 seconds it is all you shangela is the
og returning contestant she made her
first short-lived appearance on season
two and then Holly lewd her way back
into our hearts the following season
solidifying herself as one of the most
beloved contestants to grace the
workroom so much so that the guy
continued with her cameo appearances in
season four and during snatch game in
all-stars tomb this brings us to her
robbery in all-stars 3 which Automator
the first Queen to compete in three
different seasons there were nine years
between shangela's last two respective
seasons nine years that she skyrocketed
her career and continues to do so to
places far beyond most drag race alone
she has starred alongside Lady Gaga and
the stars born and has left us with
iconic moments such as this clip hold up
sweetheart
let's get it together before you want to
read I'm not even in a relationship let
alone have some old man shacked up with
us buying me all my dragon costumes I
don't have a sugar daddy sweetheart
everything that I've had I've worked for
and I worked for to get and I've built
myself so I need you to know that 100% I
don't have a sugar daddy I've never had
a sugar daddy if I wanted to sugar daddy
yes I probably could go ahead and get
one because I am what sickening you
could never have a sugar daddy because
you are not that kind of girl maybe ever
I've had I worked for and I've gotten
myself I'll bill myself in the ground
huh the only part where I'm like okay
you didn't have to throw it but still so
entertaining I con exchanged eleven oh
yeah okay so it is my turn we're gonna
put that countdown clock back up on the
monitor so my turn my pick is fan
favorite kimchi who you'll remember from
Season eight and no you won't remember
kimchi for all the drama because there
wasn't any she was a kind and warm queen
who fans love not to mention grew
insanely impressive makeup skills and
pure anime fantasy so memorable and
let's not forget her infamous line I
came to chop suey the competition and
did she ever kimchi was the first Korean
American contestant on the show and the
first Korean American drag queen on
American national television
towering over so many with a whopping
seven feet in heels which is so amazing
she made an impression especially after
opening up about the complicated
relationship with her mother with a
massive Instagram following and a brand
new makeup line which is so colorful and
awesome kimchi isn't slowing down
anything soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay so before we get into our
discussion we are launching a Facebook
poll right now you can go and vote for
the contestant you think should have won
their season in terms of our choices
here okay so aside from that amazing
performance
which I think deservedly Kim she should
have won that season just throwing it
that way what what is the hesitancy what
what's going on say it I mean I thought
she was going to win yes but I was
rooting for Naomi okay so then you were
disappointed Iommi didn't more than
kimchi I was a big fan of kimchi
I think her makeup is incredible and
again there's something to be said for
Queens who are nice and inclined and
those are people that I want to surround
myself with those are people that I feel
attracted to you know right I mean like
I like kind generous warm people and
grant she's that and I love kimchi she's
great okay ELISA saying honestly kimchi
did deserve better thank you
rachel is saying preach I think when it
comes to shangela ELISA saying all hail
so there you go hello how do ok so then
obviously you were praising you know all
of our choices but why do you think
yours is just hands down I mean I think
it's probably in people's memories
because it was last season season 11 and
rush so it's fresh it's fresh in
people's head but again I think just the
caliber of work that Brooklyn put on
that runway speaks for itself it's
Canadian and she's Canadian oh never
fear the queen of the north but no like
I think what she did was every single
time she stepped out on that runway like
look at these looks right now like they
are incredible down to every single
detail and that what is
makes such a great queen is when it's
the little things it's the fingernails
it's you know you she goes there with
everything there's so much thought into
her lugs I mean look at her she's
stunning okay miss who are you thinking
like top five the best contestants of
all time like his Brooklyn Heights up
there for you yeah I would definitely
say so I think she brought so much to
the show and being the first Canadian
right that was she was guaranteed to be
soaring through that competition just
for that fact alone she slayed the
design challenges her looks were always
so beautifully put together you know
Brooklyn got a lot of flack I think
because she wasn't somebody who was
extremely loud in the workroom they were
always telling her to kind of stuff her
personality up and that's something I
don't agree with because her personality
was always there and her personality is
just an even personality which is like a
normal person it's not somebody who's
like always on edge like ready to just
jump on other contestant right you know
I think people assume though it's
reality TV that you have to be this
bigger than average temperatures
finality and the Brooklyn came in just
very kind sweet very Canadian and people
had noticed maybe she wasn't as loud as
the others which is I don't think a
negative no and Rachel is saying on
Facebook kindness does go a long way
definitely seeing a lot of people
thinking Brooklyn Heights was her
teacher
I know but denise is saying sometimes
silence is golden agree there you go
was there anyone when you were choosing
because it must be tricky with all the
seasons of RuPaul's Drag Race was there
another one that you were inching
towards in terms of choosing for a
contestant that you thought should have
won there's so many for me if somebody
like Katya okay Malatya is do you like
cocktail of Oh Katya yeah so coffee I
actually came on into Canada pride and
she is just such a I hold the word I'm
looking for it she's such a dramatic
crazy person but she's so enjoyable to
watch and since the show Katya has kind
of you know blown away from the whole
drag race family just because she is
doing her own thing her and Trixie have
their own show she's just great I went
saw her on tour here in Toronto and
she's a comedian and she is just awesome
yeah
anyone for you I mean I love a special
or I do believe she deserved that title
but I was on the side of Trinity and
Shea okay during that season okay so
when it comes to all-stars then are you
excited for the new season I'm so
excited I love all seasons because you
are getting the cream of the crop right
these queens are top-of-the-line queens
who are coming back and want that crown
so it's the best of the best
all-stars is super exciting Dominica
thank you okay so do we have our poll
ready when it comes to Facebook okay it
is coming shortly look I'm not gonna I'm
gonna make a prediction you have a
strange
we've just based on what I'm seeing
online I have a strange feeling that
Brooklyn thing's gonna win once it mom
kimchee come on I love her but just not
as memoral in terms of everyone else
that you can think of when it comes to
the contestants I mean when you put her
against Bob okay so you don't because
I've heard a lot of people talking about
how they five Bob shouldn't have taken
listen people are gonna always thought
everything and everyone's entitled to
their own opinion and that's just part
of it but I mean I think Bob it's just
who deserves okay got you everyone has
their opinion and it can go all kinds of
ways but I think at the end of the day
Bob did deserve it I wanted Naomi and if
kimchi came in third I would have been
mad yeah
Naomi that was that a close free in
terms of choosing Naomi and shangela or
Chanel was always just the one you
wanted to pick yeah shangela was like
hands-down she's been on three times
she's just she has built such an iconic
career outside of drag race it's really
inspiring she really has she's taking it
to the next level which for me for
Beyonce yeah Beyonce you mentioned she's
in a star is born with Lady Gaga Gaga
actually hand-picked shangela yeah for
that role so I mean the Hollywood okay
so we're actually gonna go to our winner
wheel this is everything that we have
said so far this is online reaction this
is everyone here let's see who takes the
kick just wring that out there I call it
rags
Wow I call it facts there you go guys
thanks so much thanks for being here
thanks so much for informing me thanks
so much for you know making me really
excited to the next season I'm reviewing
party and we're gonna go to brunch whoa
okay I'm invited right okay thank you
course all right thanks guys write your
comments join us again next up for
another great debate
sashay away
[Music]